hey what's up i'm jordan fisher and i'm
going undercover
on the internet this is actually me
[Music]
all right imdb birth name jordan william
fisher
correct height five seven
that's not correct i'm five eight laura
can we get that fixed
i'm gonna take the silence and say
absolutely
posted twitter
jordan fisher's getting married this
year what i am yeah in november
to my best friend can't wait
so no one was going to tell me that
jordan fisher was in teen wolf or was i
just supposed to figure that out for
myself
who's supposed to tell you i don't i was
in it
i'm sure that i posted about it this was
a this was years ago
but i'm sure that i posted about it i
don't figure it out yourself
jordan fisher has a tattoo of alexander
hamilton's face i sure do it's right
here
actually it's right here
done by mr k from bang bang shop in uh
new york city
it's my favorite tattoo that i have so i
got it funny enough um
i have more like that goes up my arm so
basically
how i've decided to kind of do my sleeve
is everything elbow up is all stuff for
my family
and elbow down are moments in my career
where something life-changing happened
for me so for hamilton
it was my broadway debut which was my
first dream that i had in my life in my
career like
that was the thing that i really wanted
was broadway before i even knew that i
wanted tv and film and music and
you know all the other stuff and
hamilton was my debut which was awesome
first of all secondly i fell in love
with ellie
while i was working on that show hey
jordan do you have any advice for when
you're worried your plans for the future
won't work out
i'd say like set goals you know
have dreams have desires for yourself
and for
your family if that's something that you
want in your life but if things don't
work out exactly the way that you've
planned them
then that's how that was supposed to go
and if you're supposed to learn
something from that then learn from it
you know and you'll be stronger and
taller and wiser
on the other side of that uh can someone
explain to me why jordan fischer isn't a
disney prince yet i don't know can
someone explain to me why i'm not a
different person
because someone explained to me why i'm
not a dude quick yet i don't know man
uh how many disney princes are people of
color
i think technically one prince naveen
right because aladdin wasn't a prince
does he technically become a prince
after he marries jasmine i guess
maybe but prince naveen is the only one
of color
so you tell me
wikipedia seriously
it's actually me television fisher's
first television roles were in 2009
as a guest star on the hustler on
crackle and then i did an episode of
icarly on nickelodeon of course it was a
like small little
like under five guest star spot his
first major part
was as grace bowman's half-brother jacob
on seasons four and five of abc families
the secret life of the american teenager
this is true he portrayed he portrayed a
recurring character
holden dibbledorf on liv and maddie on
disney channel that's
all correct next youtube
oh hey so this is uh this is a clip from
me on my stream
what game is this it's twitch sings so
twitch has an extension called twitch
scenes which is basically a game that
you can download it's
very quick and easy free it's karaoke on
crack
pretty much i stream there every day
except for saturdays from 8 a.m to 3 p.m
pacific standard time
that's a lot of fun uh how hard was it
to play holden
not really very hard uh yeah not hard at
all
he's fun he's easy he was um super nice
guy
this is a character unlimited by the way
super nice guy well here's the thing too
i was friends with a majority of the
cast before i even joined the show
we just hung we hung and laughed and
made each other laugh we had a blast
posted was jordan on the floor zalada
no i've never been on the floor's lava
i would like to be i feel like i would
kill it i think that i'm a ninja anyway
what the hell is coral
i've never even heard of korra who do
jordan fisher dance with on dancing with
the stars
lindsay arnold cusick cusick is her
is her her last name now arnold's her
maiden name but i think on the show
she still goes by lindsay arnold she's
like my sister oh
look at that
[Applause]
look at that this would not have
happened
without lindsey arnold she's like she's
she's literally like my sister and i
love her to death i miss her she's uh
very pregnant right now which is also
very exciting
i have a little niece on the way so i
can't wait for that
dang man i had the time of my life doing
this thing
how long would jordan fisher be in evan
hansen well evan hansen first of all
is is sleeping right now
hopefully broadway will be back in order
in january
and the plan is for me to go back to the
show at that point
for a period of time so um we have no
answers
right now but hopefully we will very
soon i miss it though
i'm excited to get back to it what's the
song messed by jordan fisher about
women are smart they know how to get
where they need to
to go where a man is concerned i feel
like and they know exactly what to say
and like how to get under their skin and
how to like mess with their brains
our brains that's what mess is about
literally you like to mess with me
is the first lyric of of the chorus
women are smart they're too smart too
good is jordan fisher in a high school
musical
no i am not currently in a high school
musical submit what does jordan fisher
do for a living
yes that's it
i'm signing off the internet